[Música]
el gobierno de peruano anunció la
apertura de 11 investigaciones por la
muerte de ciudadanos durante las
manifestaciones que persisten en
diferentes puntos del país Asimismo el
gobierno retiró a su embajador peruano
en Honduras por considerar como
injerencia las opiniones del gobierno de
ese país centroamericano
protestas en Haití policías bloquearon
varias calles de Puerto Príncipe en
rechazo al asesinato de uniformados por
parte de bandas criminales que han
expandido su control en el país según
grupos Defensores de Derechos Humanos al
menos 78 han perdido la vida desde que
Ariel llegó al poder en 2021
en Estados Unidos los archivos
nacionales pidieron a los ex presidentes
y ex vicepresidentes revisar si tienen
en su poder documentos clasificados El
llamado llega después del hallazgo de
registros oficiales en posesión de
Donald Trump Joe biden Y Mike pence
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú el Ministerio Público anunció la
apertura de 11 investigaciones por la
muerte de ciudadanos durante las
recientes manifestaciones que han tenido
lugar en ese país de otra parte el
congreso peruano declaró a Evo Morales
como persona no grata el mismo día en
que el gobierno retiró a su embajador en
Honduras debido a discrepancias entre
ambos gobiernos veamos el informe de
Ramiro cueva Barberena
[Música]
la crisis política y social en Perú
continúa sumando episodios la fiscalía
informó que abrirá una investigaciones
por la muerte de los alrededor de 60
ciudadanos fallecidos durante las
protestas iniciadas en diciembre de 2022
y garantizó que serán con estricto
respeto a las leyes y la defensa de
Derechos Humanos
esto responde al pedido de los
ciudadanos que denunciaron excesos en
represiones policiales
hay diversas delegaciones que han sido
hostigadas por la policía y también han
sido detenidas no ha habido presencia de
fiscal ha habido una serie de
violaciones a los protocolos y
reglamentos e incluso ahora Ustedes han
podido apreciar que están violando el
ejercicio de la libre digamos protesta
la libre manifestación y tampoco han
permitido el ingreso de abogados recién
han ingresado algunos las tensiones
diplomáticas también rondan el gobierno
retiró definitivamente a su embajador en
Honduras por desconocer al gobierno de
Dina boluarte en tanto que el congreso
peruano declaró personas no grata a Evo
Morales y el expresidente boliviano
ratificó su postura
los ataques de congresistas que
justifican la represión Sangrienta
contra su pueblo con tal de aferrarse al
poder nos confirman que estamos en el
lado correcto de la historia no nos
cansaremos de denunciar las graves
violaciones de Derechos Humanos que
sufren nuestros Hermanos peruanos
mientras continúan los enfrentamientos
entre la policía y manifestantes en
contra de la administración de boluarte
e incluso grupos de izquierda
presentaron una moción de censura hacia
la presidenta la salida de la crisis
peruana aún no está Clara Ni esa emisora
pronto
nuevas protestas se registraron en Haití
esta vez por parte de oficiales de la
policía que bloquearon las calles de
Puerto Príncipe en rechazo al asesinato
de uniformados por parte de bandas
criminales que expandieron su control
sobre el país manifestantes que se
identificaron como policías atacaron
primero la residencia de lo oficial del
Primer Ministro Ariel rey y luego
entraron por la fuerza al Principal
aeropuerto de Haití ubicado en la
capital esto se dio cuando el mandatario
regresaba de un viaje a Argentina lo que
lo obligó a permanecer temporalmente en
el aeródromo el grupo haitiano red
Nacional para la defensa de los Derechos
Humanos dijo que 78 policías han sido
asesinados desde que llegó al poder en
julio de 2021
vamos a atacar a todos los ministros a
todos los directores generales tiene que
haber una Revolución los niños tienen
que ir a la escuela para que haya
Revolución
tiene que haber un baño de sangre han
matado a todos estos policías y el
Primer Ministro no ha reaccionado para
rendirles homenaje estamos en las calles
para pedir justicia de nuestros hermanos
asesinados por los bandidos saldremos a
las calles todos los días hasta que
tengamos una respuesta
la oficina de archivos nacionales de
Estados Unidos pidió formalmente a los
expresidentes y ex vicepresidentes de
las últimas seis administraciones
previas a la de Joe biden que revisen
sus registros personales para determinar
si cuentan con algún documento
confidencial la institución envió la
carta tras el escándalo que involucra a
la expresidente Donald Trump su
vicepresidente Mike pence y el actual
jefe de estado Joe biden Valentina
Torres Sánchez nos da más detalles
revisar sus registros personales en
busca de documentos presidenciales Esto
es lo que pidió la oficina de archivos
nacionales en una carta enviada a los
expresidentes y ex vicepresidentes desde
la administración de Ronald Reagan hasta
la de Donald Trump la responsabilidad de
cumplir con la ley de registros
presidenciales no disminuye tras el
final de un gobierno por lo tanto
solicitamos que lleve a cabo una
evaluación de cualquier material
conservado fuera de los archivos
nacionales y administración de
documentos la solicitud se presenta solo
días después de que los abogados del ex
vicepresidente Mike pence se informaran
del hallazgo de documentos en su
residencia de Indiana asegurando que
habrían llegado ahí por error
el exfuncionario se sumó así al
escándalo de documentos clasificados en
el que también está envuelto el
presidente Joe biden con hallazgos en su
residencia de Wilmington en enero y en
su oficina privada en el pent biden
Center en noviembre pasado en estos dos
casos los archivos fueron encontrados
por abogados que notificaron a las
autoridades y los entregaron contrario
al caso del expresidente Donald Trump en
el que los documentos fueron encontrados
en medio de un allanamiento en su casa
de Mara lago en Florida
la preocupación es que alguien pueda
acceder a ellos poniendo nuestros
secretos en riesgo la información
clasificada contiene material que debe
ser protegido por seguridad nacional
la solicitud de los archivos nacionales
incluye revisar tanto documentos
clasificados como no clasificados y
aplica las administraciones posteriores
a la de Jimmy Carter que fue el
signatario de la ley de registros
presidenciales la normativa Establece
que todos los registros presidenciales
se transfieren a la custodia de los
archivos nacionales en cuanto el
presidente deja el cargo
otras noticias de Estados Unidos la Casa
Blanca también fue escenario de la
celebraciones del año nuevo lunar chino
pero el presidente Joe biden también
aprovechó la oportunidad para rendir
homenaje a las 11 víctimas que dejó un
tiroteo en Monterrey Park California
recordemos que el ataque en esa ciudad
donde reside una gran comunidad asiático
estadounidense se llevó a cabo durante
una celebración de esta festividad china
impidió un momento de silencio por las
víctimas mortales y también elogió a un
joven de 26 años que le quitó el arma al
tirador cuando se disponía a realizar un
nuevo ataque en otro salón de baile
pensamos en los seres queridos que
quedaron atrás había vuelos padres tías
tíos hermanos amigos vecinos Pero hay
compatriotas estadounidenses Así que
únanse a mí en un momento de silencio
para honrarlos
en otros temas de la región la oficina
de control de activos extranjeros del
tesoro de Estados Unidos sancionó al
vicepresidente de Paraguay Hugo
Velázquez y al ex presidente Horacio
cartes ambos habían sido señalados de
corrupción por Washington en los últimos
meses sobre cartes han apuntado que
aprovechó Su riqueza adquirida y
legítimamente y su influencia para
expandir su poder político y económico
en las instituciones paraguayas a
Velázquez lo acusan de estar involucrado
en prácticas corruptas
y finalizamos en Honduras la presidenta
Xiomara Castro cumple este viernes su
primer año de mandato entre el optimismo
por algunos logros sociales y políticos
y críticas de la posición que consideran
que la mandataria no ha cumplido con las
promesas que realizó durante su campaña
el informe es de la agencia Efe
la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro cumplirá este viernes su
primer año de mandato entre el optimismo
por algunos logros sociales y políticos
y las críticas de la oposición y otros
sectores que consideran que no ha
cumplido con las promesas que hizo en
campaña y al asumir el poder en un
mensaje que ha sido reiterativo la
mandataria Indicó que al asumir el poder
el 27 de enero de 2022 encontró un
acelerado deterioro de las finanzas
públicas en todas las esferas
gubernamentales un alto nivel de
endeudamiento y una tragedia humana de
más de 6 millones de personas sometidas
a la pobreza extrema y una alta
inflación
su mandato No ha sido fácil No solo por
los problemas económicos y sociales que
heredó sino por otros de índole político
como una confrontación interna en el
partido libre con un movimiento interno
que quería presidir el parlamento cuya
presencia por un acuerdo con el psh ya
estaba comprometida
para 2023 Castro prevé la ejecución de
más obra social y material y que se
instale en el país una comisión
internacional contra la corrupción y la
impunidad para lo que a finales de 2022
su gobierno suscribió un memorándum de
entendimiento con organización de las
Naciones Unidas
[Aplausos]
hasta aquí es informativo en France 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web triple W punto franz24.com
para seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias Gracias por acompañarnos no se
desconecten en minutos regresamos con
más noticias
[Música]